Michael klezmer is a man in a hurry he's
been leading Saxony for the past five
years he's now in a race to persuade
voters to give him another five his is a
deeply conservative state perhaps more
so than anywhere else in Germany so on a
summer day in Batson his message is
clear Saxony is a strong state if we get
a reasonable government we can deal with
all the challenges we face better than
almost any other state in German and
people will see that we have the courage
and the strength to say things as they
are
I want the free state of Saxony to carry
on in its Sexson way trying to win that
other is called the alternative for
Germany a far-right party shunned by the
mainstream but supported by as many as
one in four Saxons
if the polls are accurate its message is
stark drastically cut immigration
stressed tradition and homeland urge
voters to reclaim their land and write a
new chapter of history it's clear we
want to be the strongest force in Saxony
our party in Parliament we want to beat
the Christian Democrats and I tell you I
think we could do it this November will
mark 30 years since the fall of the
Berlin Wall when people denied a voice
by communism cried out for the freedom
of speech and yet now the AFD is using
reminders of the old East Germany to
campaign on a slogan of fun ender
Devender complete the changes one
analyst believes this represents a
disillusionment among many East Germans
over what the end of the Cold War
brought them well I have to be quite
careful we have a very narrow channel of
political correctness and if you make
arguments beyond this channel of
political correctness well you're out of
the game and this is a feeling we did
not say
seat in establishing that kind of
democracy that we really wanted to have
when free elections returned here in
1990 the Christian Democrats won an
absolute majority in parliament on a
promise to bring prosperity and openness
now fewer than one in three voters say
they'll vote CDU and its leader faces an
emboldened far-right alternative that
wants him out
Dominic Kane al Jazeera in Saxony